[Musik]
das jahr 2021 liebe hörerinnen liebe
hörer das ist das jahr in dem autor till
raether drei bücher veröffentlicht
bisher kennt man ihm vor allem für seine
danowski krimis und im september
erscheint auch erneuerbare wollt dass es
dann band 6 und er wird hausbruch heißen
jetzt geht es aber erstmal um die bücher
die von ihm in diesem jahr schon
erschienen sind die liegen ja auch beide
vor mir das ist zum einen ein sachbuch
bin ich schon depressiv oder ist das
noch das leben heißt es ich hoffe ich
habe das jetzt auch richtig betont
und das zweite das zweite ist treue
seelen und das ist ein sehr weiten sinne
hat das ganze einen krimi plot spielt im
berlin der 80er jahre und es gibt
einiges zu besprechen willkommen
lieferte bei uns im podcast
herzlichen dank andrea ich freue mich
sehr dass ich dabei sein kann und ich
glaube ja es hat noch nie jemand doch
ausgesprochen mit den drei büchern also
natürlich habe ich das schon im privaten
hin und wieder so gehört aber mir ist
eben doch ein bisschen kalt den rücken
und
mit der aussprache dieses buch ist bin
ich schon depressiv oder ist das noch
das leben habe ich so ein bisschen herum
getan weil du hast ja auch du hast ja
auch einen podcast zusammen mit alena
schröder da geht es um das schreiben und
das autoren leben im weitesten sinne und
da hast du das glaube ich als das buch
raus kam ungefähr 25 mal pro folge
gesagt und das dann auch wirklich so
eine aussprache schon entwickelt bin ich
schon depressiv oder ist das noch das
leben das hat sich mir sehr sehr
eingeprägt dieser titel
aber was ich dich eigentlich
sommeranfang fragen sollte man kennt
sich ja vor allem eigentlich als
krimiautor für die jobs krimis was war
denn jetzt anders wenn du so als freies
schreibt die treue seelen du hast keine
genre konventionen du hast keine
hauptfigur kein ermittler der feststeht
stehst du dann etwas eingeschüchtert vor
all diesen freiheit oder war das jetzt
irgendwie etwas ganz großartiges und man
sich jetzt endlich mal frei entfalten
konnte
acht es stimmt schon mit dem
eingeschüchtert so ein bisschen also
zumindest habe ich einige jahre
gebraucht um nicht bereit dazu zu führen
also ich habe wirklich erst ich glaube
fünf kriminalromane geschrieben
bis ich mir irgendwie vorstellen konnte
mich von diesem völlig richtig von
diesem plot gerüst das der kriminalroman
hat bietet und von diesen figuren gerüst
zu lösen aber eigentlich mir ist dann
auch so im laufe der jahre des arbeitens
an den kriminalromanen klar geworden
dass mich immer am meisten soja
autoren autorinnen sagen die hofft dass
die figuren sie am meisten interessieren
das sind dass ich mich natürlich auch
aber mich interessieren eigentlich so
orte
und so bestimmte atmosphäre und stimmung
die ich mit orten verbinde und insofern
fand ich dann doch die ähnlichkeit auch
beim schreiben nämlich dann so einen ort
und eine atmosphäre mit figuren zu
bevölkern dänen wass widerfährt doch
recht ähnlich wie beim kriminalroman
muss ich sagen
das buch spielt ja in berlin der 80er
jahre ganz kurz nach dem reaktor in
tschernobyl
du hast da gewohnt du bist auch
aufgewachsen und dieses berlin ist ja
auch so ein bisschen so eine projektion
für träume auch für deine hauptfiguren
was hat dich an diesem ort oder in
diesem konglomerat von verschiedenen
orten was es ja ist also sehr sehr sehr
sehr unterschiedliche orte dieses berlin
der 80er was hat dich daran so gereizt
ja ich muss sagen also mich an ich mag
wahnsinnig gerne so so nicht ort oder so
so schwellen orte oder so übergangs orte
also ich mag im wahren leben ich bin
fasziniert von dieser
ich mag gerne flughäfen so durchgangs
passagen zwischen terminals und so
weiter und ich muss sagen auch in den
kriminalromanen die spielen dann so in u
bahn tunneln oder auf in den gängen von
kreuzfahrtschiffen und so ich mag also
gerne so orte an denen man sich
eigentlich nur kurz oder nicht so
richtig aufhält und in meiner erinnerung
ist auch west-berlin eigentlich so ein
merkwürdiger funktionslose schwellen ort
der irgendwie so gefangen ist wie in so
einem aspik seinen wabbeligen aspik der
zeitgeschichte also ostberlin hatte so
diese funktion natürlich als wir damals
im westen nur in anführungszeichen
gesagt haben hauptstadt der ddr
und west-berlin war ja aber so ein ort
an denen leute aus ganz
unterschiedlichen gründen
im grunde genommen in meiner damaligen
wahrnehmung gegangen sind um sich also
eigentlich haben sie so das leben
gesucht man hat sich aber auch vor was
zurückgezogen also in westberlin war
alles so beschützt und in westberlin war
alles subventioniert und es gab
freiräume die geduldet wurden es war
alles eigentlich super ausgestattet und
so aber es war auch sonne sind ganz
merkwürdige also sondern sonja wie so
ein gletscher artiger
stillstand der mich im nachhinein als
jugendlicher habe ich das einfach als
funktion meiner meiner eigenen
aufbruchstimmung die sich an irgendwas
abarbeiten musste empfunden aber im
nachhinein hat mich das sehr fasziniert
so als ja wie gesagt sondern welt wie in
so einer schneekugel oder wie in aspik
gefangen in der eigentlich nichts
passiert und plötzlich bricht dieses
reaktorunglück da ein
sein protagonist
lieben heißt er sein schöner
westdeutscher name geht eigentlich auch
nach berlin um was damit etwas neues
anfängt dabei geht eben auch dorthin in
die und zwar in das labor der
bundesanstalt für materialprüfung der
geht da hin weil er acht prozent berlin
auf lager bekommt und eine verbeamtung
in aussicht hat also man musste die
leute damals wirklich mit
wirklich locken dorthin das kann man
heute auch niemanden mehr erzählen wo
sie alle freiwillig nach berlin strömen
um irgendwie was kreatives zu machen
aber es war tatsächlich so eine etwas
pfiffige einen auswurf vor also so ein
anhängsel von bonn so ein bisschen farbe
abend wird aber auch so ein bisschen
frei und heute liest man lauter so
steine schmeißer und hausbesetzer romane
eigentlich über diese zeit und hat da
glaube ich auch so ein bisschen ein
verzerrtes bild
also wir haben damals natürlich bin in
zehlendorf mitte aufgewachsen wo dann
die protagonisten auch aus dass das
junge paar achim und barbara aus bonn
bad godesberg dahinziehen usw die haben
sich das natürlich so vorgestellt die
haben sich das so vorgestellt dass sie
aus ihrer bad godesberger
einliegerwohnung in eine welt von
häuserkampf und papa david bowie ist
gerade hat gerade die hauptstraße in
schöneberg verlassen und so dass ihn
seine welt kommen und natürlich hat es
diese welt auch in west berlin in den
80er jahren gegeben aber die
wahrscheinlichkeit als junges paar um
die 30 davon teil zu werden war jetzt
natürlich wahnsinnig gering würde ich
mal sagen die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
man dann da sich mit der achtprozentigen
berlin zu lage und der vom bundes liegen
schatzamt gestellten
bundesangestellten wohnung usw dass man
sich da bequem eingerichtet hat und
bequem eingerichtet hat als man
vielleicht geglaubt hat war natürlich
viel größer und ich glaube dass diese ja
also eine bestimmte
also dieser mehltau seiner
bequemlichkeit und auch eine
bequemlichkeit im kopf natürlich dass
der schon
in der summe stärker die
lebenswirklichkeit der menschen damals
geprägt hat als das glamouröse berlin
der 80er jahre es ist wahrscheinlich
heute noch genauso an will es aber nur
nicht wahrhaben klar berlin ist ist
genauso
weiß ich nicht marienfelde und
und und und reinickendorf und so weiter
wie es halt irgendwie mitte prenzlauer
berg oder die coolen teile von
kreuzkölln ist wir kommen allerdings
auch nicht nur mit dem westen sondern
auch mit dem ostteil der stadt in
berührung und zwar
durch deinen hauptprotagonisten achim
der dann irgendwann mal
probleme mit barbara hat barbara hat
auch probleme mit ihm und er verliebt
sich in eine nachbarin eine ältere
nachbarin marion die ist aus dem osten
und ein teil ihrer familie ist auch noch
im osten und
wie war das bist du damals jemals in
diesen ostteil gekommen in dieses ost
berlin ja also mein vater
hat man für das lebensthema meines
vaters würde ich sagen also das
politische lebensthema war die deutsche
teilung was den 70er 80er jahren relativ
ungewöhnlich war weil ich würde sagen
die meisten leute das war ja auch
politisch gewollt haben sich im grunde
genommen hat sich ja dieser annäherung
und in diesem ausgleich usw eingerichtet
und mein vater hat aber auch sehr enge
kontakte also der hat freundschaften
schon als student usw in der ddr und im
anderen teil von berlin gesucht und wir
haben oft also wir hatten freunde die
wir im sommer oft besucht haben in der
nähe von stralsund und wir waren auch
relativ oft in ost-berlin also ich war
bestimmt ein zwei drei mal im jahr
als wär's berliner teenager in ost
berlin
und
hat mich da dann auch auf seine art also
als teenager fühlt man sich ja schnell
überall so ein bisschen fremd aber ich
weiß noch dass ich mich damals wirklich
war schon das was mich sehr beschäftigt
hat das wirklich wenige kilometer
entfernt in der stadt in der ich lebe
eine parallele welt existiert in die ich
einfach definitiv von der sprache her
vom auftreten her also man sieht mir an
dass ich da nicht hingehöre und das war
für mich als jugendlicher eine
faszinierende erfahrung muss ich sagen
da beleidigt ich ein bisschen darum ich
habe in ost teil meiner familie erst im
mai
1990 kennengelernt
also so ein halbes jahr nach
grenzöffnung und da sind wir dann nach
ostberlin und sind dann noch nach da ein
bisschen raus gefahren nach brandenburg
na klar das war das war total
faszinierend um ehrlich zu sein weil das
war für mich so immer dass das andere
deutschland so habe ich das auch als
kind genannt so wurde mir das auch
erklärt es gibt noch ein anderes
deutschland
hast du hast du ja wie hast du da
recherchiert für für diese ganze
ostberlin geschichte also man geht ja
dann auch mit den protagonisten ich weiß
nicht ob ich zu viel voraus nehme aber
er landet ja dann zumindest
übergangsweise in hohenschönhausen im
stasi knast
wie hast du dir das alles
zusammengesucht und zusammen
recherchiert ja ich finde das ganz
schwierig sich als jemand der im westen
sozialisiert worden als diesen ganzen
thema zu nähern und das ist für mich
auch eigentlich so ein bisschen also ich
hoffe dass das rauskommt dass das auch
so ein thema des buches ist es gibt auch
so eine auseinandersetzung dann
innerhalb dieses paares achim der aus
dem westen gekommen ist und marion die
ältere nachbarin die als teenager die
ddr verlassen hat wer eigentlich
sozusagen also wir auch diese geschichte
von marion gehört und inwieweit er sich
da einmischen kann als westler als wessi
wie wir damals schon die leute aus
westdeutschland genannt haben in
west-berlin und ich habe natürlich das
gleiche
problem also dass ich so ein bisschen
als autor mich auch fragen wie darf ich
eigentlich auf diese geschichte und
diese geschichten zu
greifen und
ich hoffe dass ich auch so sachen wie
sowieso höhe hohenschönhausen geschichte
und so dass das eigentlich erzählen
schon so durch die brille auch der der
west rezeption also ich glaube dass die
die stasi erfahrungen die achim macht
die haben zum teil damit zu tun was
freunde meines vaters mehr erzählt haben
zum teil damit zu tun was sich in den
gedenkstätten und museen recherchiert
habe und zum teil aber auch schon damit
wie wir das im westen in den letzten 10
20 jahren rezipiert haben durch das
leben der anderen durch fernsehserien
wie weißensee also ich finde man kann
das nicht trennen weil man sich ja nicht
nur an mit der wirklichkeit beschäftigt
sondern eben immer auch mit texten aber
das ist für mich so eine mischung
gewesen und ich muss sagen es war doch
obwohl ich das alles auf eine art
miterlebt haben obwohl wir eine gewisse
nähe hatten war ich doch immer wieder in
der recherche verblüfft also es gab ein
paar sachen zum beispiel dass es erwähnt
es gibt diese marion die als teenagerin
in den westen gegangen ist und zwar
wirklich im grunde genommen im frühjahr
vor mauerbau 1961 nach so einem streit
mit ihrer mutter und ihrer jüngeren
schwester also die sich aus dem teenager
impuls in die s-bahn setzt und
nach west berlin fährt über den bahnhof
friedrichstraße
und
die dann aber sozusagen verpasst
zurückzukommen also die hängt also ein
bisschen rum in in west berlin und ist
gar nicht klar wohin dieser teenager
protest gegen die mutter führen soll
hier ist es nicht so richtig klar aber
dann wird eben die mauer gebaut und ich
hab dann als ich mir das ausgedacht habe
buchstäblich ausgedacht habe habe ich
gedacht ist das nicht eigentlich das ist
zu weit hergeholt das ist irgendwie so
über drama
überdramatisiert du als autor jetzt
nicht so eine zäsur der der geschichte
hat die sich wirklich so auf die
einzelnen ausgewirkt und es gibt in
berlin dieses wie ich finde sehr sehr
gelungene und schöne
grenzmuseum am s bahn nur
friedrichstraße in dem alten
tränenpalast und da gibt es so eine
vitrine zb wo ganz viele solche
geschichten dokumentiert werden also von
leuten die einfach gesagt haben euch
besuch mal stand der ernte woche in
westberlin aber auch von leuten die
gesagt haben ach weißt du was ich fahre
einfach mal eine zeitlang rüber oder so
und die dann buchstäblich durch den
mauerbau
für jahrzehnte ihrer
ihre alten wohnadresse beraubt worden
also das war soll dieses recherchieren
war eine mischung aus
wahrnehmen von schon rezipierten
persönlichen geschichten die mehr
erzielt worden sind und ausgedachten
sachen wo ich dann danach gedacht habe
okay die sind gar nicht so ausgedacht
zwei wirklichkeiten gibt es ja auch
bezüglich dieser
reaktorkatastrophe in tschernobyl die
das buch auch ziemlich prägt von der
westseite ebenso ein bisschen ändern
fast schon ein lust an der katastrophe
und macht verfolgt diese wolke und ja es
ist alles total schrecklich und im osten
wird das halt so runter gespielt als der
westen denunzierte unseren unser
sozialistisches
atomprojekt alles warm und rhone genau
alle alles super genau
lustigerweise ist da ja nicht lustiger
weise aber bemerkenswerterweise ist
tschernobyl ja momentan so ein thema was
gerade so auf pop und ich hatte das
gefühl das hat eigentlich seit 1986 nie
so eine starke konjunktur gehabt wie
momentan gerade ja und jetzt begegnet es
mir nicht nur in der fernsehserie ich
war ja auch tatsächlich da vor zwei
jahren und das soll jetzt auch zum
touristenort ausgebracht werden und
jetzt begegnet es mir auch in deinem
buch
wie wie kam es wie kam dieses thema denn
zu dir
also ich habe den eindruck wenn ich
jetzt so an die 80er jahre zurück denke
dass ganz viele oder es gibt so einige
finde ich so tun oder sagen wir diskurse
die uns heute beschäftigen und die uns
heute vielleicht auch quälen und die uns
unsere hilflosigkeit vor augen führen
die damals in den 80er jahren im grunde
genommen entweder angefangen haben oder
die so die sie ist erste mal für mich so
so ganz greifbar wurden also diese
thematik der
bevorstehenden umweltzerstörung der
zerstörung unserer welt vielleicht auch
so eine unausweichlichkeit an der wir
uns ja auch psychologisch abarbeiten
müssen in bezug auf die klimakrise und
den klimawandel
das sei es hat für mich so eine
psychologische verbindung dazu wie man
damals
dieses gefühl hatte ja tschernobyl das
war ja irgendwie klar dass es jetzt
passiert es war irgendwie klar dass das
passieren musste wir haben es eigentlich
alle kommen sehen es gab diese anderen
ereignisse vorher harrisburg three mile
island alles mögliche wir wussten das
doch eigentlich und jetzt
jetzt sind wir dem im grunde genommen
ausgeliefert also sondern das ist für
mich eigentlich ist tschernobyl im
moment sonne
also wieso du solltest nennen also
wirklich wieso ein
biografisch emotionaler anknüpfungspunkt
an dem man finde ich nochmal so
nachspüren und vielleicht auch
illustrieren kann und vielleicht auch
besser verstehen kann wie wir mit dem
umgehen was jetzt gerade passiert also
dieses gefühl immer größeren immer
weiteren katastrophen ausgeliefert zu
sein
und es gibt noch ein paar andere sachen
also ich finde dieses ost west thema was
dann logischerweise den 80er jahren
schon angelegt war dieses im grunde
genommen was trennt uns eigentlich was
verbindet und es ist ja verblüffend dass
wir 30 jahre später immer noch
feststellen dass es eigentlich eines der
ganz großen themen
zumindest innenpolitisch in deutschland
ist und auch tatsächlich so themen wie
ich habe so das gefühl dass in den 80er
jahren zum ersten mal so die diese
zweite welle des feminismus so in den
partnerschaften wirklich ankam oder
leuten wirklich so klar wurde also so
wie wir das bisher gemacht haben vater
geht raus verdientes geld und frau sitzt
zu hause und so weiter so kann das alles
nicht weitergehen aber wie geht es jetzt
eigentlich weiter und ich finde es zu
verblüffen das also solche themen und
dazu gehört eben auch tschernobyl und
dieses gefühl von unausweichlichkeit und
vielleicht auch ausgeliefertsein auf
unterschiedlichen ebenen dass solche
80er jahre themen heute im grunde
genommen immer noch unsere diskurse und
unsere auch unsere selbst zur querung so
als gesellschaft bestimmen wobei die
informationen heute einfach sehr viel
schneller und sehr viel richter da sind
also was mich wirklich fasziniert hat
als ich über dieses thema ein bisschen
recherchiert hat für meine reisebericht
damals war dass man einfach überhaupt
keine bilder davon bekommen hat man
wusste es ist irgendwie ein ein dings
bei kiew und die wetter leute wussten
das dann irgendwie und die wetter leute
haben das dann so beobachtet aber von
der sowjetischen nachrichtenagentur
kamen daneben die winkenden mädchen der
ersten parade in kiew das war das
einzige bild was sie bekommen haben und
das haben sie dann auch brettl breit
abgedruckt und dann hatte man diese
winkenden mädchen in folklore trachten
und unten drunter daneben den text über
das atomkraftwerk
diese bilder armut die haben wir
natürlich heute einfach gar nicht mehr
sondern eher das gegenteil
ja und es ist ganz interessant also es
gibt auch tatsächlich im buch gibt es
immer wieder als ich habe mich bemüht
sonne immer wieder auch so eine
gleichzeitigkeit von vergangenheit der
figuren gegenwart der erzielten zeit und
auch so voraus griffen usw
herzustellen auch um so ein bisschen zu
reproduzieren wie sich in unserer
erinnerung sachen oft zu vermischen es
gibt zum beispiel ein buch dann auch so
so hinweise auf diesen sarkophag der
dann darüber den über den reaktor
gestülpt worden ist und so weiter das
sind alles sachen die wir tatsächlich
erst viel später erfahren und
beschrieben bekommen geschweige denn
genau wie du gesagt hast abgebildet
bekommen haben ich weiß aber auch noch
damals das
ich meine ich war 17 mich ich habe mich
nicht bedroht gefühlt ich habe mich
unsterblich geführt ich war frisch
verliebt der es war irgendwie so ein
sommer da hat wirklich tschernobyl für
mich in meiner biografischen erfahrung
ganz anders als wir die erwachsenen
ihrem buch hat keine große rolle
gespielt aber wenn ich mich an etwas
erinnere dann war es genau das ist
interessant dass du das jetzt sagst war
es genau auch etwas durch diese bilder
armut entsteht ja auch buchstäblich so
etwas unheimliches du weißt nicht wie es
aussieht und du kannst es dir im grunde
genommen nur ausmalen und inzwischen
wissen wir egal was wir uns ausgemalt
haben es war tatsächlich noch
schrecklicher vor ort aber das war schon
auch wirklich hatte damals also diese
unsichtbare bedrohung war auch wirklich
gerade unheimlich daran ja diese diese
ich glaube das ist auch so ein bisschen
das was die was die 80er jahre als
epoche irgendwie irgendwie ausmacht so
es hat so was oberflächlich sind es ja
immer sehr sehr bunte bilder die wir da
sehen und
unterschwellig dann immer der saure
regen und die atomare bedrohung und das
kann man ja dann immer sehr leicht als
als übertreibung hinstellen weil es eben
nicht wirklich fassbar ist ja das stimmt
und es ist wirklich auch tatsächlich so
[Musik]
ich glaube dass es auch
auch dieses leben in westberlin also
diese
es gab tatsächlich natürlich auch eine
große bilder armut was überhaupt so das
leben im osten und so weiter angehe also
man kannte das dann als westberliner
familie wenn man auf der transitstrecke
die meiste zeit über die bundesstraße
nach norden gefahren ist oder über das
hermsdorfer kreuz irgendwie runter nach
nach hof oder so aber das war ja man hat
sich wieso ich durch so korridore
bewegt die auch so nicht ort waren man
hat nicht ddr fernsehen geguckt das
heißt man hat also nicht mal so richtig
die selbst produzierten bilder der ddr
wahrgenommen und sehr sehr viele
menschen die ich in west berlin kannte
sind auch eigentlich nie im osten
gefahren oder so war es war irgendwie
deprimierend aufwendig hat 25 mark
gekostet und so weiter
gleichzeitig grau sagte meine mutter ist
es ja gerade alles grau genau genau also
es ist so man lebte aber tatsächlich in
so einer scheinbar bunten tempo
häuserkampf
weiß ich nicht nena welt die aber von so
was grauem diffuse umgeben wurde
ja was glaube ich auch so
tiefenpsychologisch vielleicht über die
zeit so ein bisschen den westlichen
blick auf die ddr mehr geprägt hat als
wir uns heute vielleicht noch vielleicht
noch eingestehen wollen
wahrscheinlich müssen wir auch erst mal
mit dem blick auf die auf die gute alte
bundesrepublik noch mal ein bisschen
klarkommen weil das war ja auch nicht
alles bunt und bunt und prima ja also da
war ich total glücklich muss ich sagen
über einen leserinnen kommentaren
kollegin von mir das buch gelesen hat
gelesen dass er hat gesagt ist etwas
jünger als ich hat gesagt dass ihr durch
treue seelen nochmal so klar oder
überhaupt erst klar geworden ist
wie nah so die
das ist im grunde um wieso nachkriegs
roman ist und wie nahe diese
nachkriegszeit einfach in den 80er
jahren noch war also so in denen in der
art wie die menschen sich geäußert wie
die menschen sich ausgedrückt haben auch
in sonnen bestimmten weltbild und in
dieser ständigen
diesen ständigen zurückgreifen der
eltern räder generation auf
kriegserfahrung auf nach
kriegserfahrungen und auf dieses das
bunkern von lebensmitteln in west-berlin
und es sprechen über den russen und so
weiter also der stillstand dieser dieser
westdeutschen und dieser west berliner
gesellschaft und auch dieses selbstbild
ist was im grunde genommen
ich sagen würde also ich glaub berlin in
den 80er jahren hatte viel mehr
ähnlichkeit und auch die bundesrepublik
in den 80er jahren hatte wahrscheinlich
viel mehr ähnlichkeit mit mit mit der
bundesrepublik der 50er jahre als mit
dem deutschland zehn zwanzig jahre
später ja die historisierung gesetzt
glaube ich jetzt so ungefähr 1 habe ich
das gefühl dass man da so ein bisschen
darauf blickt als was wirklich
abgeschlossen das ok bundesrepublik ist
jetzt echt vorbei
ich würde gerne nochmal auf das zweite
buch zu sprechen kommen das ja auch noch
da legt der
erste satz in diesem buch
ich blättere lautet
ich habe nie daran gedacht mich
umzubringen ich habe nur sehr oft daran
gedacht mich hin zu legen und nicht
wieder aufzustehen ich kenne das
natürlich so ein bisschen man will ja
immer auch mal liegen bleiben und nicht
aufstehen aber wie um himmels willen
verträgt sich dieses lebensgefühl das du
lang mit dir rumgeschleppt hast damit
dass jemand einfach mal locker flockig
drei bücher im jahr raushaut das ist
erklärungsbedürftig
naja also locker flockig und
ich muss ganz groß leider doch als
technische fußnote angegeben es werden
zwei bücher in diesem jahr gewesen wären
treue seelen nicht völlig zu recht vom
verlag aus corona gründen vom vorigen
herbst verschoben worden wäre aber ich
kann die frage auch
psychologisch beantworten also ich muss
schon sagen als ich habe erstens also
ich hab viele jahre als journalist
gearbeitet ich bei der zeitschrift
brigitte gearbeitet und war da
angestellt und ich wurde im nachhinein
sagen dass ich das
angestelltenverhältnis
gekündigt habe weil ich diese freiheit
haben wollte morgens und auch haben
musste morgens unter umständen liegen zu
bleiben und auch mal zwei oder drei tage
hintereinander morgens liegen zu bleiben
und ich muss sagen dass ich
glücklicherweise in den 15 jahren die
seitdem glaube ich vergangen sind
nächsten sogar noch mehr inzwischen 17
16 17 seine freiheit gefunden habe
sowohl mit diesem impuls zu leben liegen
bleiben zu wollen nichts machen zu
können sich deswegen durchaus auch zu
schämen und zu lernen dass man sich
vielleicht nicht deshalb schämen muss
aber gleichzeitig die energie die ich
habe dann eben in meiner eigenen zeit so
zu managen dass sich als autor arbeiten
und auch gerne arbeite und ja dieses
jahr sehr produktiv arbeiten weil ich
das gefühl habe dass ich in dem moment
wo ich am rechner sitzen oder am
notizbuch oder am schreibblock und mich
mit dem
buch beschäftige an dem ich gerade
arbeite
das in dem moment sozusagen die welt die
sonst so auf mich ein stürmt und die
mich oft überfordert die wird in dem
moment so din a4 oder din a3 groß und
ich sehe vielleicht noch so in meinem
augenwinkel links und rechts
meine quellen und bilder die ich mir
bereit gestellt habe oder so und
ansonsten habe ich das gefühl dass ich
alles kontrollieren kann in dem moment
in dem ich einem buch arbeite und das
ist einerseits ein großer gegensatz und
daher auch eine große erholung gegenüber
der art wie ich sonst das leben
wahrnehmen nämlich als sowas über
forderndes und unkontrollierbares und es
ist natürlich nur wahnsinnig schöne
illusion
weil das brauche ich nicht zu sagen man
kann beim schreiben gar nichts
kontrollieren und es ist tatsächlich
doch ne große
es ist chaos und es ist es ist
unvollkommenheit aber irgendwie gelingt
es mir beim schreiben diese illusion
hier ist eine welt die ich kontrollieren
kann aufrecht zu erhalten und darum kann
ich
ein buch im jahr normalerweise schreiben
das ist eigentlich schon mehr als klima
das ist wirklich schon mehr als
du schreibst ja sehr intim in diesem
buch muss ich sagen über dich über deine
mutter über deine das klingt böses wort
aber befinden sich keiten über das was
du so fühlst
ist es ist wie fühlt sich das an damit
dann an die öffentlichkeit zu gehen und
das sind so in buchform auf die welt
loszulassen
also ja das ist natürlich
für mich schon auch ich habe eben das
wort kontrolle benutzt also es ist für
mich tatsächlich
sowohl so ein bisschen so eine
strukturierung einer gedanklichen
beschäftigung mit dieser
mittleren
depressionen wo man eben eigentlich noch
so im arbeitsleben und im familienleben
scheinbar funktionieren kann aber eben
nur auf absehbare zeit und mit hohen
kosten für alle beteiligten er ist so
eine strukturierung für mich und dadurch
empfinde ich das nicht also
als so ein kontrollverlust und
gleichzeitig habe ich mir natürlich sehr
genau überlegt was in dem buch
drin steht ich muss aber ganz ehrlich
sagen also es macht mir nichts aus es
macht mir unter umständen auch freude
darüber zu sprechen und ich empfinde das
als interessant und als als bereichernd
aber ich habe zum beispiel aus dem buch
keine lesung gemacht weil da hab ich
dann so gedacht dass wenn ich
irgendwelche macht wahnsinnig gerne
lesung ist eigentlich für mich so mit
das schönste am
autorinnen da sein aber aus da bin ich
schon depressiv oder ist es noch das
leben aus dem buch habe ich keine lesung
gemacht weil dann diese vorstellung
davor menschen das was doch sehr
persönlich ist in seiner unmittelbaren
begegnung situation vorzulesen und
darüber dann auch noch fragen zu
beantworten
das wollte ich dann da muss ich sagen
das wollte ich dann doch nicht haben ich
habe ja schon gesagt wir alle wollen
eigentlich morgens immer gerne mal
liegen bleiben ich glaube das gefühl
kennt so ungefähr jeder wann ist dann
für dich der moment gekommen dass du
gesagt hast so nee das ist nicht mehr
normal das ist nicht mehr das liegen
bleiben wollen was was jeder hat das ist
das ist jetzt schon langsam wirklich
pathologisch oder da muss ich jetzt mal
irgendwohin gehen und mir helfen lassen
also bei mir haben sich diese haben sich
so stress erscheinung ganz ganz
klassisch akkumuliert also als
arbeitnehmer in
stress erkrankungen ich habe damals dann
eben immer noch gedacht na ja also
sobald du dann gekündigt hass und deine
zeit frei einteilen
kann es dann wird es sicherlich auch
alles aufhören und ich hab dann über
jahre lang so wege gefunden an
diesen depressiven stimmungen selber und
teilweise auch mit anleitung von
verhaltenstherapie und so zu arbeiten
aber im grunde genommen hat sich so
dieses gefühl dem leben relativ macht
und und kraftlos ausgeliefert zu sein
das hat sich schon einfache weiter
aufgebaut und ich hatte dann irgendwann
ich vor 34 jahren wirklich in so einer
familiären überforderungssituation
ja wirklich so eine art zusammenbruch wo
ich mich dabei ertappt habe dass ich
irgendwie auf der straße bei der suche
nach dem restaurant
geschrieben habe lasst euch alle in ruhe
ich will nicht mehr ich kann nicht mehr
es mir alles zu viel irgendwie sowas in
dem stehen wo man dann schon so
sich als analytischer mensch natürlich
auch von außen betrachtet und denkt
okay jetzt das geht nicht mehr dass das
ist also das ist für dich und auch für
die anderen
muss es einen anderen weg geben und er
ist müssen wir geben das das dass du
dich so nicht mehr fühlst
hast du auf das buch viel resonanz
bekommen ja und zum teil wirklich also
so dass ich
[Musik]
also ich habe viel persönliche resonanz
bekommen und
ich habe auch resonanz aus meinem
freundes- und familienkreis muss dann
oft so ist auch das wusste ich gar nicht
so genau und warum hast du denn nie was
gesagt und es tut mir immer so ein
bisschen leid aber ja erstens handelt
das buch so ein bisschen davon dass ich
jahrelang nie so richtig was sagen
konnte und dann ist natürlich vielleicht
auch tatsächlich doch nach all den
jahren für mich irgendwie das buch die
art und weise wie ich dann eben versuche
etwas zu sagen aber
ich bekomme auch wirklich tatsächlich
immer noch viele direktnachrichten und
und e mails usw von leser innen die
einfach sagen ja ok vielen dank jetzt
weiß ich dass ich zumindest mit diesem
gefühl es müsste doch irgendwie besser
sein obwohl ich ja immer noch schaffe
aufzustehen nicht so ganz alleine bin
und
das freut mich dann immer sehr ich habe
andere als auch oft ein schlechtes
gewissen weil ich dann nicht gleich oder
nicht angemessen an bord das sind diese
mails wo man eigentlich besonders schön
oder besonders gut antwortet vilnius
schrecklich ja ja
im september kommt dann noch das nächste
buch der danowski krimi
kasse den vor oder nach treue seelen
geschrieben eigentlich also ich habe
treue seelen
anfang 2020 beendet und ich habe in der
paten pandemie phase letzten jahres dass
depression buch geschrieben und ich habe
danach also jetzt diesen winter und
dieses früher habe ich den dann osci
krimi hausbruch geschrieben das ist die
chronologie für spätere generationen
bitte seid mir nicht dass sie seitdem
noch was fertig geschrieben habe nein um
gottes willen andrea natürlich und nein
natürlich überhaupt nicht aber ja ich
habe schon
also
es ist manchmal ehrlich gesagt
schmerzhaft als auto und ich habe auch
phasen gehabt in denen ich lange nichts
geschrieben habe es gab auch wirklich
jahre wobei mir zwischen büchern wo ich
auch gar nicht wusste ob ich jemals
wieder ein buch schreibe oder wo auch
ansonsten vier jahre oder so zwischen
büchern anlagen und wo ist dann einem
auch weh tut oder weiß ich nicht wo es
unangenehm ist wenn anderenfalls aber
woran arbeitest du eigentlich gerade
wann kommt mal wieder was von dir weil
man es selber nicht so genau war es und
ich muss sagen also der beste weg um nie
wieder gefragt zu werden woran arbeitest
du eigentlich gerade oder wann kommt mal
wieder was von dir ist zwei oder drei
bücher in einem jahr zu veröffentlichen
dann fragt ein kirchenlied macht und ich
mache auch ich recherchiere gerade für
einen für ein buch was
in den 70er jahren spielen sollen
ist das ein prequel
es geht nicht um die gleichen figuren
wie treue seelen und es geht auch ein
bisschen um eine andere welt aber ich
bleibe wenn es alles so läuft wie ich
mir das vorstelle tatsächlich auch in
westberlin weil mich diese
länger ich mich damit beschäftige desto
mehr fasziniert mich diese welt in aspik
in berlin wirst du jetzt auch deine buch
premiere feiern bzw wenn dieser podcast
online steht wirst du sie gefeiert haben
dafür wünsche ich dir alles gute und
viel spaß und einen wunderbaren abend
und für unsere hörer nochmal
zusammengefasst treue seelen ist bei btb
erschien hat 352 seiten kostet 20 euro
und das andere buch bin ich schon
depressiv oder ist das noch das leben
von till raether bei rowohlt erschienen
128 seiten kostet 14 euro und auf den
newski freuen wir uns dann im september
vielen vielen dank liebe till dass du
dabei warst vielen dank andrea danke für
die einladung
sekundär material zu den büchern von
till raether finden sie wie immer als
links in den schoß oder auf unserer
seite
www.kath.net / bücher - podcast bücher
mit da finden sie auch die und adresse
unter der sie uns erreichen können
bücher podcast faz.de da können sie uns
mitteilen was immer sie auf dem herzen
haben licon abonnieren und sternchen
können sie uns auch geben in den pott
ketzern bei spotify oder auf instagram
da heißen wir etwas bücher diesmal
verabschiedet nur ich mich andrea diener
das nächste mal ist wahrscheinlich auch
mein kollege fridtjof küchemann wieder
aus dem urlaub zurück der sich
verdientermaßen erholt und ich danke
ihnen bis bald
[Musik]
[Applaus]